over an intensive two year two day
meeting
um I shared my information about the
Biden family's Financial transactions
with CFC
including specific dollar figures I
never heard back from the doj but
instead of showing appreciation for my
whistleblowing I became Public Enemy
Number One I'm not a republican I'm not
a Democrat I have no political motive or
agenda
I did it out of deep concern
that if the bidens were to come to power
the country would be facing the same
traumatic Russia collusion scandal only
this time with China
well we all know what happened next the
US attorney's office in Manhattan
unsealed charges this week against Luft
and after he made those claims about the
Biden family business with China and now
we're learning some Curious details
about the lead prosecutors in the Loof
case via Chuck Ross at the Free Beacon
now not only did the assistant U.S
attorneys Catherine gosh and Daniel
rickenthal conduct the 2019 interview
with Luft where he made these initial
claims both of them both have
contributed exclusively to Democrats
gosh made 35 contributions in the 2020
election cycle to Biden's campaign and
the DNC while rickenthal contributed to
the 2008 Obama Biden campaign while in
private practice joining me now is
Miranda Devine Fox News contributor New
York Post columnist she's the one who
published the Loof video that you saw at
the top Miranda there certainly is
um there's a lot out there about luff
the left is circulating saying that he's
really a you know a pro-china plant and
you know he's not someone as credible
that he's a spy et cetera but these
prosecutors are the same ones that
interviewed him in 2019 the fact that
we're learning more about them and their
donations that's relevant is it not
yeah I guess so I mean it is New York
and so it's not surprising to find
Democrats uh in the prosecutor's ranks
um and look it's only a few hundred
dollars although I would say that
Catherine gosh is uh 35
contributions to Biden in the DNC in the
2020 election cycle would suggest that
she was pretty keen on having Joe Biden
beat Donald Trump that year
um but look I I don't think it's really
fair to cast aspersions on their
professionalism just based on who they
donated to but I do think it is really
curious the way that they've handled uh
the both the Patrick ho case and the gal
luftcase now Patrick ho was the The
Joint business partner of both this
Israeli Professor Gail Luft who's
currently a fugitive and Hunter Biden
both Hunter and his Uncle Jim Biden and
gal Loft we're making money out of cefc
this Chinese Energy company that Patrick
ho worked for and when Patrick ho was
rounded up by the southern district of
New York arrested and charged and then
convicted on bribery allegations during
his trial the very same prosecutor Dan
rickenthal he asked the judge to not uh
to to basically redact the Biden name
from the evidence before the jury and he
said there was not just no point having
it and this was one of the reasons that
gal Luft says that he felt he would not
get a fair trial in New York because he
would have been trying to hide now
they're getting special treatment again
I mean once again
there's a standard of justice for them
and everybody else Miranda important
details thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else